in this problem it is desired to install
a new maintenance drop shaft B in an
existing sewer between two existing
maintenance holes A and C how deep must
the drop shaft be in feet in order to
reach the ground surface assuming it is
constructed so that its max depth is 12
in below the sewer invert elevation at
the proposed
station so the first thing that we can
note about this problem is that you
don't need the man ual um we just need
to use geometry here so the first thing
we can do is take a look at what we've
been given we have drop shafts A and C
as well as the proposed drop shaft B
this is a 36 in RCP sewer and this is
the ground surface up top the table here
gives us the
stations and the ground surface
elevations for all three of our drop
shafts it is not giving us the invert
elevation for B and the problem itself
is asking us to find the total
[Music]
depth of the drop shaft so the first
thing we can do here since this is a
linear sewer and there's a new drop
shaft being put in in between drop
shafts A and
B um is we can solve for the slope of
the existing
sewer and that's as simple as our rise
over our run so the first thing we can
find is the Delta y between manholes a
and
c and that's going to
be given right here in our table so the
invert elevation of the
manhole at a n c has been given to be
ft minus
44.25
ft and that's going to be
7.25 ft so the invert at C is 7.25 ft
lower than invert at a we can do the
same thing here and get our gamma sorry
our Delta X and that's just going to be
the difference between the two stations
here
so stations written in this value can
simply be thought of as the hundreds
column on this side and everything after
it on this side so 2 + 0 0 will
be 200 ft
and 0 + 25 will be given as simply 25 ft
so this is 175
ft now if we were to divide 7.25 our
Delta y over our Delta X of
175 we would get a slope of
0.414 feet per feet and that's going to
be the slope of our existing sewer
step two is going to be to
find the invert elevation at the new
station
B and that's because y = mx our old
slope intercept form here technically
plus b but there is no there's no B
component in this problem
so what we can do now is so we're
finding the invert elevation at B here
so we know the slope and we know the
difference in distance between these two
points so we can say that the distance
between B to to a is going to be the
difference between these two stations so
again 1+ 0 0 is going to be equal to 100
ft and 0 + 25 is going to be equal to 25
ft and so that's going to be our
X distance here and then our m is our
slope which we calculated out to be
0.414 feet per
feet and this is going to be equal to
3.1 ft
so
B is
3.1 ft
deeper than the invert elevation
at
a so now we can look
for our third step which is going to be
finding drop shafts
B drop shaft B's bottom
elevation so the
dropshaft bottom elevation at B is going
to be found by
subtracting the 3.1 feet we calculated
here from the 4.
41.5 we have at drop shaft
a so we've got
41.5 ft
minus
3.1
ft but we also have an additional value
because we can see that in the problem
statement it
wants it notes that the max depth is
going to be 12 in below the sewer invert
elevation of the proposed station so
this would be so that the drop shaft
extended beneath the sewer itself so
that the sewer could reside within it so
we have to subtract one more foot AKA 12
in here
from from our initial depth provided by
a so this is just going to give us
47.4
ft and then finally we have step four
which is just find the total depth of
the drop shaft bottom
so depth is going to be equal
to ground
surface at
B
minus the drop
shaft
bottom
elevation so that's just going to be
418 given
here minus
47.4 which we've calculated and that's
going to give us
10.6 ft and that's all it takes to solve
this particular particular problem uh
the only thing you'd really need to know
here is that an invert elevation means
the bottom of the
sewer there's nothing else from the
manual since the rest of this is just a
geometry problem and that's it